my colleague from the nfl media group
back here on the rich eisen show with
the latest as we get set for week 13
kicking off tomorrow night on the triple
cast on nfl network amazon prime and of
course fox between the cowboys and
saints ian rappaport back here on the
rich eisen show how you doing ian i'm a
little confused why um
i
to me isn't it obvious how good of a job
lsu is i mean notre dame is a is a
definitely a good job historically like
if you believe in pomp and circumstance
and name recognition and all of that
like notre dame would be a cool job to
have had
but
as far as like having the opportunity to
win a national championship
like isn't it obvious that lsu is much
better i mean they have the entire state
of louisiana which is a talent rich date
to themselves
it is a highly recognizable name they
have incredible facilities they have a
great fan base you get to eat gumbo all
the time
um one of the best jobs in the country
no and and and in terms of putting a
football team together uh i imagine you
know with all due respect and i know you
have an sec background ian rappaport
um that
um with all due respect to whoever this
individual is i imagine if you're
comparing provosts the lsu provost
compared to notre dame's is like a
turnstile compared to notre dame's
so when you're trying again just as far
as the academic oh yeah when you're when
you're being told you can get that kid
and you can't get that kid and i'm sure
lsu is just like bring it what do you
got you know and notre dame's like yeah
i don't know i'm sure there's so many
different ways
that brian kelly can build a
championship team that he hasn't been
able to or found a lot of headwinds
attempting to
at notre dame i imagine i mean that's
got to be part of the allure as well for
him to go
you know i mean and and he's come close
to notre dame he's been in the in the
playoffs through the last four years
probably right so i mean he's definitely
had good teams but like
les miles
won a national championship at lsu
no i i know that my my point about all
this is ian again no offense michigan
man i know no no no because uh you know
my my college for yours is alabama
correct ian rappaport right you've spent
some time in alabama
no i mean i i i went to columbia but i
covered mississippi state right where my
lovely wife which is right for now i
covered alabama for three years so
you've been there i feel like i have a
fairly intricate knowledge that's
exactly what i'm saying correct so um
so uh my my i guess hub is the midwest
and anybody who's been rooting for
college football in midwest or went to
school there in the midwest the number
of times you'd run into notre dame fans
and they would tell you that they're
just different they're separate from
everybody else they are even though
we're competing against each other for
recruits and on occasion on the football
field oh my goodness gracious this
they're different they're better they
even have a higher power that we don't
have right so you'd hear that so to see
a coach basically pass newt rockne
and then look around the landscape and
get more money and then a better spot
like that
this is what we would call this is what
we in the midwest would call a field day
moment for for us
is what i'm saying
ian
you know i mean i and i and look i feel
like i can be as petty as anyone
i respect the pettiness oh i'm on a
petty tour right now i mean is this
petty palooza with me right now uh ian
this week for me
oh he's having tom petty yeah yeah i'm
all richard i'm i'm i'm up name of petty
uh lori petty uh give me a penny that's
who i am
yeah she was in uh she was in point
break right that's what i'm thinking
about being wrapped up
information man all right let's get to
the the the i guess the nfl part of this
it was an nfl coach reached out to by
lsu or
usc at all did did tomlin really have a
tire kicked or that was just a a wish
list and all that
i mean i would say i have no idea
whether or not he really did but
the
the problem with reporting on
colleges like the interest of college
programs is that it is not like an nfl
program where the owner reaches out to
the agent and starts a dialogue like in
the nfl if you have interest like the
owner calls the coaching agent they have
some back channel or not back channel
background conversations in november and
december you kind of start the process
and you go from there in college like
let's just say for instance that
oklahoma was interested in clift
kingsbury let's just say that
um
well the way it works is
the relative of a booster or the high
school friend of a booster reaches out
to a high school coach that knows cliff
kings very well he goes hey man like
would you be would your guy be
interested and he goes i don't know like
let me run it by two different people
and then they tell someone and that
someone else tells kingsbury and then he
either says yes or no like that's the
way it works in college so i would
imagine because
there's no like official dialogue until
you're basically getting ready to give a
guy a job like it's not a real interview
process here it's like an anointing
process so
you know i would imagine that every
major college opening reached out to
several nf coaches including nfl coaches
with college backgrounds it seems like
they all got to know and then
everybody's moving forward well how do
you think the price tags for lincoln
riley and brian kelly at usc and lsu
respectively will affect
the price tags for head coaches in the
nfl because i mean the brian kelly deal
that he got uh just in terms of terms
and dollars
um and it looks just like the gruden
deal that we were all wondering why the
raiders bestowed on john right a couple
of years ago with the tenure and the
dollars that's what you're seeing right
now from lsu and you know you throw in a
couple of bought houses and private jets
for lincoln riley and
suddenly how do you think some nfl head
coaches today are going what's up with
that
you think yeah i mean maybe um
you know the college contracts have
always been weird they've always been
insanely long-term because if they're
not long-term and someone recruits
against you and it's like this guy's not
staying there forever so some genius
came up with the idea we're just gonna
lock these guys in for ten years you
know mel tucker gets a 35 year contract
but like can get out kind of whenever he
wants like so the contracts are all it's
real money but it's the contracts are
all fake you can get out of any of them
um
the nfl contracts aren't like that
because i think if you're an nfl coach
like let's say you're
okay let's say you're clipped kingsbury
right you have one more year left and
then you have an option year you don't
want a long-term deal you'd rather a
short-term deal kingsborough is getting
ready to make a lot of money
i think i mean he really is so like he'd
rather a short-term gear where he can
re-up rather than a 10-year deal where
that's what he's getting
all right that's twice you've mentioned
his name is he interested in any of
these jobs in kingsborough
okay no all right
why do why is urban meyer's name keep
coming up because we're all just like
talking about him and um and his he now
has his many losses in in his first uh
11 games as head coach of the jaguars he
had the entire time at ohio state is
that what we're talking about is that
true that's true yeah that's true
um
the reason we're talking about urban
meyer is because we want to talk about
urban meyer okay and i think that's what
happens a lot of times with these things
like you know first of all again let's
just play the the
make-believe game or whatever let's just
say urban meyer is interested in one of
these shops let's say he's interested in
notre dame
so they are not going to wait until
mid-january or the first week of january
to hire it is not going to happen they'd
lose an entire recruiting class in
college that is currency it will never
happen no one waits so for urban meyer
to leave the jaguars for notre dame he
would have to leave now right now
take the job
give his players the finger on the way
out give him the petrino i think is the
proper chart
write a little letter and put it in the
lockers or whatever it is and then that
would be it
and and his reputation would be ruined
for a long time petrino never got over i
mean he got money on a lot of money but
he never got over his reputation as a
complete
you know whatever um
i don't see anyone in the nfl doing that
i really don't
ian rappaport here on the rich eisen
show let's talk about the cowboys and
the saints who do you think
is going to be active and inactive for
that one as we're close to 24 hours of
kickoff
um
so let's start with the cowboys you know
it doesn't sound we'll see we'll see if
he practices today but it does not sound
great for amari cooper um he is
unvaccinated he had coveted he is still
having symptoms
and it does seem like the players just
judging from their own interviews the
players who
are not vaccinated who get cold but do
seem to get hit very hard and it sounds
like amari cooper got hit very hard um
you know is he ready to play a game
after being out 10 days having no
conditioning and still being sick seems
far-fetched to me so that that doesn't
seem great
um seedy lamb does seem like he's gonna
play
uh i would expect him to come off the
injury report today's wednesday uh today
um so that is good news as far as the
quarterback i would expect it to be
taysom hill
uh who got first team reps this week in
practice
um
and
who maybe kick starts the offense or
maybe they realize
not they'll get some some players back
um
but not all of them is command
is camaro one of those players
that comes back do you think for the
same you know we'll see on the injury
report today but i don't get a great
feeling on camera i really don't
you know like he's banged up he's got
his knee it's been a while like he's
still limited
anything's possible but i just
i don't feel very good about it i got
cedric wilson's another one because
we're talking about a depth chart he he
had an ankle injury despite having 100
yards receiving on thanksgiving day to
what do you think about him certainly if
cooper doesn't look like he's going to
be able to go
you know i do not feel good things
uh about cedric wilson as well so i know
he's been out the last two days
um i don't believe he's gonna play wow
and of course mike mccarthy's not gonna
be there and dan quinn's coming down
from the
from the booth they're really gonna
remove him from his
his physical place of coordinating them
that's worked so well all year so they
can get him down on the field to run the
show
uh
i was both surprised at that i am too to
be honest with you i mean that that that
one kind of surprised me like you i i
wouldn't want to touch the coordinators
that's what the raiders did when gruden
uh disappeared suddenly that's what most
people do
you know
poof there goes gruden um
yeah i mean it's you know keep
everything as the same as possible and i
don't mean to minimize the role of the
head coach but like
game day responsibilities is some but
physically being on the sidelines is not
like of the utmost importance like
what's the difference right right so i
don't know i was a little surprised
about that ian rappaport here on the
rich eisen show what is the scoop with
dalvin cook you were right in the
middle of all that this week oh yeah
what's going on with that i mean you you
report that as labrum's torn uh and mike
zimmer says it's possible he plays this
week what's going on yes uh i i noted
the comments of uh esteemed head coach
mike zimmer um
i like mike zimmer he is uh he has his
viewpoint and i have what i believe is
uh the facts according to a source
several sources actually
uh torn labrum he actually has another
torn label so he's got two torn legumes
um was playing with one of them
and
you know does not sound like he is going
to play for two weeks
which is bad but on the other hand like
you see someone get carted off with what
looks like a significant injury and then
they grab
at an area that seems to be their peck
you know that's
worrisome extremely worrisome the fact
that it's a torn labor man could only
miss two weeks
and then be back for i believe the
monday night or against the bears i
think is their game in three weeks
that's really good so you know nothing
great but certainly a much better
situation than it could have been and uh
what's the scoop with roger's toe uh is
it true like i mean
you hear surgery and you think oh my god
a foot surgery is significant um and
then he he says that it's possible he
could have it on a monday and he's
playing on a sunday and you could put
nothing past him you know so what do you
have
he's right about the timing so i was
told no surgery but they are going to
follow up
based on he said on monday and just see
hazard now no surgery just rest i hope
it heals by itself if they got surgery
it would stabilize it and basically kind
of make it immobile
um
and let it let you know have that help
the healing but he's right i mean it
would be sounds like a very quick and
minor surgery which you know it's like
my dad was just minor surgery is on
somebody else
um
but he would if he had it on monday he
would be fine to play on something and
then what about uh the cardinals we're
just assuming they're coming off of a
buy and it'll be kyler murray and
deandre hopkins and the good times
rolling again is that the way it's
trending in arizona that
how i just punched my ceiling by
accident sorry careful um wow what a
ceiling that must be very low for you uh
ian
i don't know what you mean rick no i'm
just saying you punch a ceiling i mean i
i i couldn't push that i couldn't punch
the ceiling right here
you know are you in the car are you in a
car no i'm in my i'm roaming my my
basement office i got the flu vaccine
today so i'm i'm trying to do like
circles with my left arm because that
apparently makes it so it doesn't hurt
okay that actually works but that's what
they tell me all right anyway okay very
good i have a very low ceiling in my um
are you questionable for sunday is that
what you're telling everybody right here
you're questionable for game day morning
on sunday or what uh
we don't have a problem we don't have a
probable designation anymore okay so i
would just say i will be off the injury
report by sunday okay no designation
whatsoever very good uh what are you
doing what are you talking about
cardinals yes cardinals um i it seems
like they're going in the right
direction i mean we'll see what they're
listed as but i wouldn't be surprised
that both these guys are full
participants today kind of paving the
way for them to play on sunday and you
know they withstood it right they had
two of the top guys out they went
two-in-one with colt mccoy
that is how you do it if you're an elite
team in the nfl all right last one for
you ian uh how many coaching uh um
vacancies do you think there's gonna be
it's now december 1st
usually this is the time when we start
to think about it because there's only a
month left in the season this time
around it's six weeks left in a season
so i'm front loading the conversation
how many coaching vacancies do you think
there will be in the national football
league coming up
you know usually it's the same number
usually it's six to eight i don't get
any sense it would be less than usual
no i'm not sure the pool of candidates
is so fantastic
but i would say six to eight is probably
the ballpark there i mean you know
they'll be a surprise like always um
but i i think it's gonna be kind of like
a usual year my guess
all right ian thanks thanks for thanks
for the time greatly appreciate it thank
you sir you be well all right good stuff
talk to you all right back at you that's
uh rap sheet
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here